They say history repeats itself -- I'm a big
believer in this theory, which is why I try
to spend more time on this show talking about
big ideas and political philosophies rather
than day to day political rumblings.
Most of our political debates and media coverage
has devolved into catchy sound bites and zingers,
usually staged around some sort of publicity
stunt instead of true substantive debate.
Even protesting these days seems to be more
about screaming and hashtagging than making
a coherent argument.
Just think back to the election itself -- did
the candidates and media spend more time on
the issues, or on the circus?
I think the answer is pretty obvious.
Understanding political philosophies helps
to guide us through the endless noise that
comes out of our political machine.
This is why I've tried to talk about issues
like gay marriage in a context which shows
you can be liberal and for gay marriage because
you want gay people to be treated equally
under the law, or you can be libertarian and
for gay marriage because you don't want the
government involved in a contract between
two consenting adults.
If you understand the philosophic underpinnings
of liberalism and libertarianism in this case,
it can bring you to the same conclusion.
Without understanding political philosophy,
your thoughts on any day to day issue will
be guided more by your feelings than by facts.
We see plenty of facts over feelings in our
public discourse these days, and it's partly
why we are so divided as a nation.
By the way, that isn't to say feelings don't
matter at all, because we're humans and they
do, but the way we are governed has to be
based on what is empirically true, not just
what makes us feel good.
Beyond just knowing political philosophies,
knowing history is an incredibly important
part of having a well rounded understanding
of how the world works.
Think of how many people you talk to who claim
to know everything about what tax system is
right or what foreign policy is best.
Next time ask them something specific, like
"tell me the reasons a flat tax is wrong"
or "remind me the history of the middle east
during the ottoman empire."
Everyone on television seems to have the need
to pretend they know everything about everything.
These are the people you have to watch out
for the most.
If history does repeat itself, I'm not exactly
sure what it's repeating right now, and no,
I don't think we're repeating Nazi Germany
even thought it's a very trendy phrase to
say that these days.
We truly are at a unique crossroads in American
politics, which I can't directly compare to
any other time.
It's not just America having two diametrically
opposed political parties between the Left
and the Right.
With Donald Trump in the White House, we now
have a presidential wild card who has turned
political alignments on their head.
For example, Democrats are now suddenly arguing
for states rights because they don't like
all the federal power Trump has with his series
of executive orders.
This political chaos is also pushing massive
amounts of people sick of the extremes on
both sides into some sort of amorphous middle.
There doesn't seem to be a political leader
for this New Center, nor anyone mainstream
talking about it, but mark my words it's here.
The key to this New Center's success will
be who sees it first and turns it into a political
movement.
Whether that means a new party, or a reforming
of one of the two major parties, or something
else altogether, that remains to be seen.
On top of this new political alignment, we
also have access to information like never
before.
As I often talk about, we walk around with
the world in our pockets --- right now, you
can connect with someone across the globe
just as easily as with someone across the
street.
The genius and power of the internet's ability
to change our physical world can't be over
stated.
This connectivity has started revolutions
in the middle east and shined light on the
inner workings of our government via Wikileaks.
But at the same time, so much of the information
is not just noise alone, but noise intended
to deflect, confuse, and upset you, made by
people who want to profit off you or outright
control you.
Of course if our mainstream media had done
their job for the past 8 years, which is to
be the guardian of truth in our society, then
maybe the importance of the internet wouldn't
be so vital to our functioning democracy in
2017.
Unfortunately cable and network news dropped
the ball at almost every corner and here we
are.
They cozied to power instead of keeping it
in check, they colluded with the people they
were supposed to keep watch over, and they
partied with the very politicians they were
supposed to be reporting on.
Now, suddenly the mainstream media is trying
to get its mojo back by being hard on Trump,
but I would argue it's basically too late
to do that.
Actually it's kinda sad watching them flail
around knowing that less and less people are
paying attention to them.
Even right now there's talk they they are
going to cancel the White House correspondents
dinner because so many in the media dislike
trump.
Think how insane that is... when they like
the President they can party and drink with
him...
now they don't, so the jig is up.
Maybe we needed them to guard the guy they
liked as much as the guy they don't like.
At the same time we more and more cater the
News to ourselves, we don't listen to pundits
we like, we impugn the motives of anyone we
disagree with and we block friends and family
who dare have a different opinion.
All of this is exactly why we need to know
history and philosophy more now than ever.
We need to understand where we came from so
we can know where we're going.
We need to know why the founding fathers wrote
the constitution the way they did.
We need to understand why they yearned for
freedom and liberty in a way that seems archaic
to us now, but is possibly the most important
lesson we could learn in 2017.
With all this in mind, I can't think of a
better guest for this week as we continue
our partnership with the fine folks over at
Learn Liberty.
Dan Carlin is a radio and TV personality who
hosts two podcasts, 'Common Sense' and 'Hardcore
History.'
As a self described political martian, Dan
uses thought experiments to try to make some
sense of the modern world.
On his podcast Hardcore History he hosts long,
well thought out presentations of historical
events set to the backdrop of how we might
view these events thought a current day lens.
While he isn't technically a historian, he's
proven himself to be incredibly adept at storytelling
history in a way that offers some modern day
answers to historical events.
If history repeats itself then lets make the
next repeat a little more enlightened... and
a little less painful... than the last go
around.